the first votes were counted in New
Hampshire just after midnight Donald
Trump campaigned in the Granite State
late last night with his family and
Republican running mate mike pence major
Garrett is outside trumps polling place
it's public school 59 here on the east
side of Manhattan major good morning
good morning Donald Trump and his
advisers believe they are on the cusp of
victory but that they will need a surge
of election day turn out to push them
over the top and the frantic final days
of this campaign a surprising state has
emerged as the centerpiece of trumps
push for 270 electoral votes Michigan
which has 16 of them he hasn't voted
Republican since 1988 there's no place
I'd rather be from my last rally right
here in Michigan at a midnight rally in
the usually democratic state of Michigan
Donald Trump framed today's election as
a middle class rebellion today the
American working class is going to
strike back finally basking in the glory
of his last campaign rally Trump
squeezed in his most popular campaign
stick one more time I just want to ask
you one question if you don't mind at
one o'clock in the morning who is going
to pay for the wall
hundred percent in New Hampshire Trump
claimed he secured an endorsement from
New England Patriots quarterback Tom
Brady he called today and he said Donald
I support you you're my friend and I
voted for you in Florida where early
vote totals have Trump backers
encouraged the candidate lighten the
mood by reaching into the crowd for a
flimsy likeness of himself nice head of
hair I'll say the move served as a
symbol for Trump's closing argument only
he can unmask the Washington system his
supporters have come to loathe it's time
to reject a media and political elite
that's bled our country dry Florida
North Carolina and Ohio formed the
foundation of any successful Trump
strategy to win the presidency other
states the campaign will look at tonight
Pennsylvania New Hampshire in Colorado
to name just freaked Trump us to here to
vote any minute at PS 59 in midtown
Manhattan then after that like the rest
of the nation he will watch and wait
thanks major